okay so the unwritten rules of Hollywood
yes your book without giving away too
much from those who have read the book
what are some takeaways where they were
completely surprised whether it was a
chapter whether it was a tip or two that
you can write I think that some of the
things that people came away with that
they were not expecting was that there
really are people that want to help you
even though there's some there's some
people that would rather eat dirt than
help you most people somebody help them
so they're willing to help I have a
chapter on mentoring and how to treat
your mentor right and I think a lot of
people didn't understand that you don't
go up to somebody and say will you be my
mentor a relationship has to develop and
then how to make the ask I talk about
the Hollywood ask which is a particular
kind of an ask so that you don't back
somebody into the corner what people say
is and this is people these are people
also have gone to film school I didn't
understand how the business worked and
now I understand you know what I should
be doing what I shouldn't be doing how I
should be talking about myself what the
whole thing about networking and I hate
the word networking but how you connect
with people in an authentic way so that
a real relationship forms and how that's
important you don't have to be that
smarmy networker which chapter do you
wish you'd read when you first decided I
know you grew up here but that you want
it to be in the business which chapter
do you say you know what I could have
used that 10 years ago
that's a really interesting question
which of the chap now have to think back
to the chapters it was a while back I
think it was about how to prepare for a
meeting and how to follow up because I
didn't know I didn't know what you say
to people I didn't know how informal it
was or how formal it was I have a
chapter about what to wear I probably
would have appreciated knowing that
because you don't know how formal or
informally you should be in in what
circumstance and also how to connect
with people how to meet people what to
do when you meet them I I wish I had
known that stuff but but mostly how to
behave so that I didn't put my foot in
my mouth so I didn't make big mistakes